In this course you will improve your command
line skills, your Linux skills and your hacker
skills. This course is a walkthrough of the
abandoned war game from over the wire.
It's very similar to a CTF, which is a type
of security competition where participants
attempt to solve challenges on their computers
to earn points. sabia Sachi will guide you
through a series of security challenges involving
the Linux shell remote connections, and SSH,
consider trying to solve each challenge yourself
first. Today, we are going to see the walkthrough
of this bandit over the wire wargame. So in
the internet, I came across this particular
website that is over the wire and they were
having certain challenges out there. So if
I take you to this over the wire, main website,
so we have got several WarGames that we will
surely for in the next video that we'll be
covering. So today, I'll be covering about
this bandit and what I found in this particular
challenge is on or in the particular game,
it's the kind of a CTF thing that we will
be receiving flags in each and every stages
of this game and this particular game or this
particular war game is very good for the newbies
or for the people who are just starting out
and are not so much familiar with the Linux
terminal. So, if you actually play this game,
you will be much more efficient or your skills
in using the Linux terminal will increase.
So, today we are going to learn Linux by solving
this particular challenges and this particular
challenge wargames. So I am assuming that
you are having some basic ideas and basic
knowledge of the Linux terminal commands like
what is MK dir, what is Ls, what is Rm what
is what is cat? What is Nano, all these things.
So let's go ahead and let's start solving
the challenges one by one. So, first, what
I'll do is I'm inside my folder, or TW and
I'm gonna make a directory known as bandit.
So let me get inside it. And level zero says
that the goal for this level is for you to
login into game using SSH. So we are going
to use SSH but I will be using SSH paths minus
p and here goes the password and SSH. And
they have said that the host to which you
need to connect is bandit dot labs over the
wire.org. So bandit dot lab dot over the wire.org.
And the user name is bandit zero, so the username
is banded zero. And the port is the password
is valid zero. And once you log in go to level
one, the port is default to zero, so minus
p triple to zero because SSH runs by default
on port 22. So this is all about it. And before
that they have said that the password is branded
zero. So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
write bandit zero and save it on a file named
zero. And I'm going to do some command substitution
over here. And I'm going to write CAD zero.
So basically what I'm doing is I'm making
a file called as zero and inside that file,
the password of every level will be stored.
Like I'll be making different files and on
different files, level the hospital restored
and I'm using SSH pass I'm providing the password
using command substitution. So cat zero will
give us output as band zero and band zero
will be supplied to the switch minus V which
stands for password in SSH pass and then we
are telling SSH to connect to this particular
host. As the user bandits zero in the port
triple to zero. So let's hit enter and let's
solve bandit. So let's go to the next level.
They say that the parser for the next level
is stored in a file called readme. So clear
LS we got a readme file over here. And if
I do get read me hit enter we get the password
for the next level out there. They say use
this password to log into Bennett one is the
SSH whenever you find a password for a level
use SSH to log into that level and continue
the game. So for them, it is that in each
level we will be getting the password as the
flag and that password will help us log into
the next level. So this is a password of bandit
one. So let's exit and though the password
to one. Let's use SSH pass Get one and let's
switch the user to one. In Level One we have
got the passer for the next level is stored
in a file called minus let's go ahead and
let's see, we have got a file called as minus,
so it's a special character file. So, to see
the special character file, we have to use
a filter that is dot slash minus and hit enter
and we will be able to see this particular
file if I do not use this dot slash thing
and if I simply give minus this means that
Bash is taking this that I will be given some
character which will be treated as some kind
of switch for cat command. But this is not
the case, we want to specify that minus is
my file name. So for that, we are giving the
slash and hence we have received the password
for the next level
level two, let's save that. And let's switch
to band two they say that the parser for the
next level is stored in the file spaces in
the file name located in the home directory.
So, if you wonder that these are four separate
files, then you are probably wrong because
if I do ls minus L A, you can see it's a continuous
file like it is a single file having spaces
in its file name. So, the way we can write
is that is Cat spaces backslash space in this
file and this is the actual way how we write
or how we include space in the script this
is known as escape sequence and we will simply
copy it and if I do not give this backslash
what will happen is if I give it like this,
this will be treated as four separate file
names. So cat spaces CAT and CAT this and
cat file and this will be treated like this
manner, but we do not want that we want to
specify or we want to say the bash script
that include this particular spaces into a
single file. So the way we say that by including
this backslash
and it's of level three. So level three, the
password for the next level is stored in a
hidden file in the inherit directory. So,
we have quartered directory over here CD in
here. So, if I do ls we have we can see nothing
over here. So LS minus L a will show us that
there is a file called as hidden or we can
also do ls minus a which will list all the
files minus S stands for all probably I use
them all. So dot hidden so I will be using
CAT dot hidden and simply we will be receiving
the file or receiving the flag which is a
password for the next level ups let's switch
to level four
level four stage that the password for the
next level is stored in your human readable
file in the in her directory okay. So CD in
here LS we have got several files. So, cat
minus 500 Okay, I did a mistake, I have to
specify dot slash minus 500 Because it is
starting with a special character which I
said in my first challenge. So, we have got
some content which I do not need to see. They
say it is present in a human readable file.
So we have to check for the file type and
the way we do it using the file command. So
file, then dot slash minus file 00 They will
say that it's an open PGP public key, we can
say is 01 It's a data file 02 It's a data
file. And likewise, we can go till 09 To see
which type of file all the files are. But
this is the kind of monotonous work so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to use a bash script
by using a for loop. So for i n, they're using
a command substitution LS do file dot slash
dollar i 10. So, what this is going to do
is I is a variable so I in LS LS will list
all these files and on each iteration, on
each iteration, every file name will be stored
inside this variable i and I am saying that
on each iteration, do file dot slash file
names so this will result in giving us all
the file types for each and every file present
in the current directory. So we can see that
file seven is an ASCII text. If you don't
know what S stands for ASCII stands for American
Standard Code for Information Interchange.
Let me get it out while I'm in minus 507 and
we have received the password for our next
level
that's a bit as five let's log in into planet
five this game is easy till now let's see
what we can see in the next level. When it
level five says the password for the next
level is stored somewhere under the inherit
directory. So let's go to inherited a tree
we have got several folders out here. So let
me do ls minus R to get a recursive view of
what files are present inside each folder
are means recursive. So I'm going to list
all the files recursively. So, there are tons
of piles over here I want to do ls minus R
L. Hopefully that will work. And yes, this
is showing us the data of each and every file.
And the more better way if I do ls minus l
a r l or l r whatsoever you write s answer
all L stands for a detailed list and R stands
for recursively I will get to see all the
hidden files all the folders each and everything
and say that we have to find the file which
is human readable 1233 Bytes inside that it
is not executable at all. So one thing we
can do is this is the file size these are
the file size. So we can manually go and search
for the file size 1033 wide and manually go
ahead and run the file command to see whether
it is human readable or not. But we do not
have to do so much of things what there is
a tool called as fine so find dot dot min
search in the current directory so find the
command I'm telling find a search in the current
directory which is human readable those The
size is 1033 Bytes C is suffix that we need
to give in find a command which says that
C stands for bytes. So 1033 bytes and it is
not executable so not operator and executable
kill the bow. So this is the whole command.
Let me explain you the thing find dot find
dot will search in the current directory and
search for a file which is human readable
post size is 1033 C. C is a suffix that we
use represent byte and which is not executable
so not as an operator and we are stating executable
so so it is not executable. And if I hit Enter,
I'll be getting the file name right over here.
If I simply do cat we can see a we will be
getting the password for our next level. Let's
go to level six. level six says the parser
for the next level is stored somewhere on
the server. So find slash because it is stored
somewhere on the server slash main search
on the parent directory or in the root directory,
and has all the following properties. Let's
see what are the following properties first
property is owned by user band seven. So minus
user bandit seven, owned by group bandit six.
So minus group. Mandate six. And it is 33
wide insights. So minus size 33. See, if I
hit enter, we get to see lots of permission
denied messages. Interesting. We shouldn't
be seeing these messages. Right over here,
we can see that there's a file which is not
showing us permission denied. These are some
messages that are been shown to us. But this
file is not showing us any message and it
is stating when seven not passwords, so what
we can do is we can redirect all these messages
into the garbage bin. So the way we do it
is if I just write over here, too, and redirect
all the problematic messages to a test when
present in Linux call as dev null to represent
all the problems all the messages that are
not our usage, all the errors and all. So
it will be redirected in this dev slash null.
And we can see the only file that is not shown
any error, or so we'll be covering it, get
the file name, and we will be receiving the
password for the next level. And that's great.
Let's switch to Android seven. And I'm storing
my passwords locally in my local machine so
that in case my connection breaks, I can log
in directly. So level seven says that the
parser for the next level is stored in a file,
or TXT next to the word million. So l s, we
have got data dot txt, wc minus l. There are
txt gives us that there there are 98,005 minutes
and seven lines if you're wondering what this
means, word, WC stands for word count and
minus L is a switch which stands for the count
the number of lines present in this particular
file. So data dot txt is having 98,507 line
and out of those lines, I have to find the
word million next to which my password for
the next level is present. So I'll be doing
CAD data dot txt, and I will be redirecting
its output or I'll be sending its output to
a tool called as grep, which is pre pre installed
in Linux shell. So grep and search for the
word millionth. So if I do so grep will take
the output of cat data dot txt and we'll search
for the word million in that output. And we
have received the password as stated it is
next to the word million. So let's exit out
of it. And let's to go eight and
let's switch to user eight. grep is actually
used to search a word and let's see what's
level eight. As for us, the possible The next
level is stored in a file or txt and is the
only line of text that occurs only once. All
right. So probably there's the vertex D and
mu c minus l that will take C there are only
1001 line. So if I dare to do cat data dot
txt, my whole terminal will be full of text.
And these are all the random passwords which
they have said that has been repeated several
number of times. So beforehand, what I'll
do is I'll be sorting them in ascending order.
So salt, so this is sorted and we can see
that each password or each string has been
repeated several number of times. So I do
not want repeated text I want unique texts
so unique. So only these text will be shown
to me that are unique and they're repeated
strings will not be shown. But I want to know
how many times these are how many times each
string has been repeated. So for that I will
be using unique minus C minus C stands for
count. So each line has been repeated 10 times
and they have said that it is the only line
that occurs only once. So we have got a line
that occurs only once. So this is the probable
password that we are searching for. And one
more thing we can do is we can use grep minus
v 10 minus v is stands for actually grep is
used to search for a particular word from
a file minus v is used to tell grep that do
not search for that word and give us the output
except that word. So I will be getting the
output except the word 10. That is not present.
So, if I do not use this grep command, so
what are we getting that all the files or
all the strings having the number or the string
10 in them, but if I use minus V, I'll not
be getting all this and I'll be getting only
the line that is not containing any 10. So,
this is the line. So, that's great. Let's
save it in nine. Let's log in to band ID nine
and let's see, what do we have in Level Nine
the pastor for the next level is stored in
a file erotics T in one of the few human readable
strings preceded by several equal two characters.
So it seems that it is not a human readable
string, or human readable file is a data file.
So if I dare to print the file, so we have
got a we have received a binary file. That's
great. Let's do clear, I will be using the
strings command strings is used to show us
the human readable strings out of a binary
or our gibberish file. So cat data dot txt
so whichever file has any readable strings
or human readable strings are present that
will be shown to us. And they have said that
the password is preceded by several equal
tools. So the password is starting with several
equal to So grep equals. So we can find that
this is the password because it is starting
with several equal tools every line has equal
to but not starting with several equal to
but these lines are starting with several
equal to and stating that the password is
this and like this is the password out of
intuition. So let's save it as 10 Let's use
SSH first once again, let's switch the user
from bandit nine to band 10 and quickly see
what's present for us in band aid level 10.
The password for the next level is stored
in the file dot txt which contains base 64
encoded data. Okay, so it's encoded data that
we have received that is base 64. I have done
a mistake that there are no tapes D so it
is a very sensitive West 64 encoded data and
the way you can recognize that it is ending
with two equal twos. So normally you get data
or txt and we will be sending the output to
a tool we'll call as basics default is installed
by default and minus d for D chord. And we
will be receiving the password VEC SR four
is already installed in the nutshell especially
in Ubuntu you can already get it and don't
know about other Linux distros. So let's save
it, paste it in 11 And if you're wondering
how I know all these commands now of course
I'll be I've been using Linux for so many
years but the way you can remember all the
switch is number one practice and number two
by visiting their manual and by seeing what
are the switches and what else you can do
with the command. If you are not aware how
to do that, let me show you. So let's first
go to bench 11 and let us see what is there.
The parser for the next level is stored in
a file dot txt where all lowercase and uppercase
letters have been rotated by touching position.
Okay, so, ls the txt Now you might have seen
me to use switches like ls minus L LS minus
A L A LS minus A LS minus r how can I do so,
right? Because I have been using a command
that is mad man stands for manual and manual
LS man ls this will show me all the things
all the commands all the switches that I can
actually use or that is actually present for
a particular command. So if I use the arrow
keys to navigate around the manual, you can
go ahead and read all the switches and use
it and practice it in your day to day life.
So you can see that I've been using capital
R in my previous challenges it was for recursive,
there has been many, several different things
as well, you can see L for long listing format.
So this is how we use it. And you can use
minus q to quit it with the manual. And this
is how I remember all the switches. So no
worries, if you actually forgot some switch,
you can go ahead and type man stem the following
command that we're not aware of. And then
you can go ahead and read about that particular
command. So enough of talk we have guarded
or TXT Get Data txt, it is Rod 13 encoded.
So it has, so each alphabet has been rotated
13th 13th number of times, not 14 times I
would say it has been rotated at the 13th
number. What I'm actually trying to mean that
if I say Rod 13 algo. Hopefully by seeing
the image you can understand this is Ratan
algo. A is represented NBSO cspd, sq and vice
versa. So G you are. So G for t, u for h and
r for E. So it's T H E, so it's a de and probably
it will be password is and there is a random
password. So I'll be copying it. And let's
go to all Rod 13. And as we go into this web
site, also on website rot.com, you can select
your rod algorithms rotation and Gordon strat
self rotation, so they have used rock 13 I'll
be pasting it and they will be showing us
the correct that record a string will be shown
to us decode is the correct word that I can
use. So exit and let me save the password
and 12. Let's go and mess with level 12. Level
12 says that the password for the next level
is stored in a file data dot txt. Let's go
ahead and switch to band 12. Until then, I'll
be having some water. So level 12 stays that
is the parser for the next level that is stored
in the file dot txt, which is a hex dump of
a file that has been repeatedly compressed.
For this level, it may be useful to create
a directory on the temp in which you can work
using MDR for example within that role, okay,
so we have to a lot of what is the extraction
and decompression all those things. So if
I do ls zero dot txt and cat data dot txt,
okay, this is a hex dump if you're seeing
a hex dump for the first time so welcome or
Congratulations, you have seen a hex dump
for the first time so let's see what we can
do with that. Before that let me make a directory
in the temp folder because I don't think that
I'm having permission over here to make a
directory MK DIR for example what to say?
No permission denied Very good. CD tmp. Can
I make a folder over here am Korea Serbia
Oh file exist seriously? Who made it? Service
Archie great I mean of course many people
are using the same server and I'm not the
only person having the the only names Versace.
Okay
MK dir what to say? Game. Okay, so gammas
does not exist. Let's see the game. Let's
copy the data dot txt into that game folder.
Let's go to game. And great. So we are having
this file over here. Now let's get data or
TX D and give it to x x D minus rx x d is
a tool that is used to generate as well as
reverse a hex dump. So minus R stands for
reverse. So if I hit enter, we can see all
those of stuff some binary stuff probably.
Let's do clear and let's save this file into
another file for this Simple hex dump. If
I clear it out if I do ls we can see two files
that are a txt in hex dump and if I do file
hex dump you can see it's G zip compressed
data. If you're not aware what Jesus is, in
Windows we are having rar In Windows we are
having zip file similarly in Linux we are
having GZ. So I will be renaming this hex
dump into hex dot g said which is the extension
of gz file, and I will be using Jesup to decompress
this gz file. So remember, I have renamed
or changed the, the name of the file hexdump
to hence them tar gz. And now hexdump doesn't
exist. So if I just show you LS, you can see
hex dump.gz exist now i will be doing GZ minus
d G zip is a tool that is used to decompress
or compress files, so just zip minus d and
then had some tar gz ID. If I do ls we can
see that this file has extracted another file
called as hex dump. And let's see what is
the file type of that particular hex dump
file. So it's B zip to compress data, which
is kind of similar to G zip as well. So I'll
be renaming it to be set to pi two because
there used to be zip two, so it's extension
is BZ two. If I do ls you can see hexdump
dot visit to exist. So be that into B zip
to minus d hexdump dot visa two. So they have
produced hexdump it has produced Hensen file
hexdump again, a gz file. So MVX dam x dot
g Zed again, GS F minus d, oops, sorry, GS
F minus minus d, the extracted hex dump again.
Now it's a tar archive you can see it's POSIX
tar archive. I'll be using star minus x B
x VF as we have actually means or you can
write is x VF like this as well X stands for
extract V stands for verbose and F stands
for File. So what I've got I've got probably
hex then forgot the final exam. So tar minus
x VF then hex dump. So verbose will actually
tell me that what file or files this tar archive
has been has extracted for us. So it has extracted
data five dot bin for us. So let's see by
data of five dot when it's at archive again.
So this time data by dot bin, it has extracted
data six dot well let's see what is the file
type of data saves dot when it's a visit to
so MB data six dot when into data six dot
PennDOT does that too. If you can understand
what I'm doing, I am actually renaming the
extractor output since it's a visit to compress
data, I have just changed the extension and
visit to minus d and then it has extracted
for us data six stored pain once again. And
how did I know that because I have already
changed the name data sector well into data
six or winner visit to so let's see what our
what type of file it is it is a tar archive
again. So let's go data set stored when right?
It has extracted data a dot when read data
eight, not well. It's a gz file again. So
MB data 8.12 to data.when.gz and GS F minus
D data a dot window cheese and we have received
data a dot bin once again. So file data a
dot well it's an ASCII text. So let's write
cat data a dot bin and here is the password.
The password is this for our next level. So
there's 13 in level 13 We have got the the
password for the next level is stored in Etsy
when it passed when it 14 And can only read
by user manual put in for this level you do
not get the next password but you get a private
SSH key that will be used to log in the next
level red let's see. So we have got SSH key
dot private. Okay so we are going to use this
private key to login into SSH or login into
bandit 14 using SSH so I'll be using SSH mandat
14 And since we are logging in using like
inside the bandits server itself, so we will
be using local hosts and also they have noted
that local host is the host name minus p is
tripled to zero for sure and we are giving
an identifier that we do not have the password
but we do have a private key so use this private
key to identify me as mandatory so it's asking
for permission and giving it yes and we are
inside mandate 14 A quick Who am I you can
see when it 14 And I will be navigating into
the et Cie folder where there is a folder
called as when it passed and I will be extracting
the password for granite 14 So I have done
so let's open another shell over here real
quick or DW banded. Over here present all
the passwords echoed as 214 Let's see what
challenges we have in 14 the parser for the
next level can we retrieve where somebody
in the past so the current level on port 30,000
on localhost Okay, so the password for the
next level can be retrieved by submitting
the password the current level. So we have
to submit the password or the current level
on the post localhost and on the port 30,000.
So, we will be using Netcat for that Netcat
is a Swiss Army Knife Swiss Army tool sorry,
Swiss Army tool which is used to make a TCP
UDP connection between systems which are also
used to listen for boats. So you will understand
what I'm trying to say or rather it will go
to man and see. You can see it's an arbitrary
TCP UDP connection that listens, you can see
all the descriptions you can pause the video
and read it. So NC and connecting on localhost
on port 30,000 and it is asking me for the
password of the current level. So if I provide
the password and hit Enter, I will be getting
the password of the next level. And let me
close it for the next level. So if I hit Exit
and exit echo, store it as 15 and let's go
to bandit 15. The straight away from 14th
From 13th we have we are going to bend the
15th That's a great let's go to Manage 15
The password for the next level can we retreat
with someone in the past with the current
level of to portrait trees is the one on localhost
using SSL encryption. So in Netcat, we were
using HTTP or normal connection, clear text
protocol but here we will be using HTTPS that
is SSL encryption SSL stands for secure socket
layer.
So for that we'll be using a tool called as
open SSL. Actually, I haven't been using a
tool for so long so I kind of forgot was the
format so probably it's open SSL as kind minus
connect local host is the host name and I
think I have to give the port name like this
30,001 And then I have to give the password
so before that, let me are right path is equals
to believe save the password. Yeah So saying
read our blog like this is the output of the
thing, if you're confused what actually happened,
let me close the connection, let me clear
it. But we save the password in a particular
variable so that I don't forget, I'd be using
open SSL, I will be telling that my client
is with whom I want to connect is localhost.
And the port I want to connect is 3000 30,001.
If I hit enter, it will show me all the messages
that connected can't use a cell get server
name whatsoever, some headers, some certificates,
some more information, some handshakes and
all some hex terms again, so we're not really
interested. And you can see there's a prompt
that is waiting for us to give the password.
So we pasted the password over here. And if
I hit Enter, it says correct and gives us
a new password if we could see this block
right over here. So I have given the password
of this level that is binded 15. And we have
received the password of valid 16. So let's
stop it great. Let's connect to bandage 16
Real quick. The credentials for the next level
can be retrieved by submitting the password
the current level to a port on localhost in
the range D 1000. To 2,001st Find out which
of these ports have a server listening on
them, then find out which of this fix SSL
and which don't. So there is only one server
that will give you an exponential the other
will simply send back to you whatever you
send it to it. So we have to do some port
scan and some network enumeration. So we're
here's the best tool I can only find that
in my arsenal or in my toolkit that is Nmap.
So Nmap scan the local host from the port
range 31,000 to 32,000. So NMAP has said that
these are the ports that are open. So I'll
be telling and maps Okay, and web do one more
favor scan the local host in the given port
of mine only scan local host on the given
port that is 31046315183169131790 and 31960.
So do not search anything beyond this mentioned
port because you will be taking much more
time. So I have specified only the port that
you want to scan for and I want to know the
service versions of each and every port each
and every port is running some services. So
I want to know all the service versions and
the time that you are going to use is four
so the greater the number the greater speed
it is going to reach. So it is like in NMAP
I'm probably not sure the t value is ranging
from zero to five. So zero is slow and five
is fastest. So I use T four. So I'm telling
NMAP the scan the local host for these ports
and tell me what are the service versions
are running hopefully from the explanation
you have understood. And of course it is going
to take a lot amount of time. So let's see.
So out of all the given ports we will be we
have to find which port speaks SSL or which
word has SSL service running on. So we have
to work to save separate those and there is
only one server that will give us the next
credential and other will sell back to you
whatever you send to it. Okay, so probably
I have to give the password Okay, here they
say that can be achieved by submitting the
password or the current level. So you have
to submit the password of level 16 to one
of those ports using open SSL because they
have said that it is using open SSL now if
I use the up arrow key in the terminal right
here so I'll be able to understand that. Only
80% done and 14 seconds remaining. So let
it do the scan. Okay, we have got that lots
of data 100% done okay. Nmap scan report.
These are the posts that are Oh Pattern these
are some what are some responses? So the ports
that are open are this 131518 and 31790. So,
I will be doing open SSL s client minus connect
we had before that, that et Cie valid pass,
when it's 16, let me save the password real
quick, let me copy the password. Rather, what
I can do is simply I can do X clip over here,
not installed. Not a problem, what x clip
does is clip will basically take this particular
output and it will save it in my clipboard,
so I do not have to copy it once again, no
problem. I have copied it and let's use open
SSL. So open SSL s underscore client minus
connect localhost on the port, the first port
is 31518. And it says echo. So let's say 31518.
That feeling says that it will probably gives
us the output that we are providing it. If
I say the password Yeah, this was that server,
which they say that others will simply send
back to you whatever you send it. So if I
say hello, or are you I am fine. Subscribe
to my channel, all sorts of things. Channel.
So this is not the code that we are interested
in. There was one more port that is 31790,
let's say. So instead of this 31790, let's
hit enter. And let's paste in the password.
And okay, so we have received correct and
we have received a RSA private key file. So
let's copy it Ctrl, Shift C. Let's go to temp
folder and make a directory called game it
exist. One, two, okay, CD game, one, two.
And let me make a copy of it. So nano RSF
file. And I'll be pasting the certificate
over here, or the survey the private key.
And I'll save it. So there's my RSA file.
And it is currently having permissions that
all people can at least read it the user who
has created the file can actually read write
it doesn't matter. Groups can read write it
which matters and other people the whole world
can read it. Private Key needs to be very,
very secret. Private Key is not for everyone
to share. So we have to change the permissions
so I will be using ch mod this change mod
maybe 600. What does 600 means that four stands
for read. Two stands for write and one stands
for execute. So six means that for this user
for user, six means read and write only so
like it's for and to read right? Zero means
nothing for groups and zero means nothing
for us for the people. Hopefully that makes
sense.
So if I do ls minus ln right now you can see
that only I am having read write permissions
Read Write, as I said, Read stands for four
and write is two. So four plus two is six.
So that's why six and everybody's having zero.
And now I will be using SSH. So SSH minus
i RSA file bandit 17 At the rate local host
minus b 2220. Yes, and we are inside bandit
17 Who Am I? We are when 17 Let's go to band
17 and I've been a big mistake by removing
that thing I would have saved the band 17
Password anyways not the password at least
or other what I can do is get at sea band
pass and bandit 17 All right this is a password
in case the connection is lost I can actually
login into Windows seven is in this password
when layer level 17 says there are two files
in the home directory passwords not old let's
see LS password a new password at all yes
and the password for the next level is impossible
dot new and in the only line that has been
changed within password at all impossible
dot new okay so what this says that there
are two files password dot old so there's
the old password file and a new password file
the or the content of old password file has
been duplicated into password dot new file
except one particular line and we have to
find that line which actually contains a password
of the validating user. So for that we will
be using a command called as def def then
password dot bold pass word dot new diff command
will give us the difference between password
old password as new and which line has been
changed and which line has been added. So
this line has been removed and this line has
been added so I will be copying this line
which is the password for bandit 18
Let's exit and go but bandit only 18 And did
I do a mistake oh we're in minus 16 Sorry
I thought I was in my root
directory let's save it Thank God I cook I
cross checked it anyways invalid 18 We have
got on manage 17 We have what Okay, so we
have solved it let's go to bandit 18 First
of all okay, so whenever we're trying to log
in, it says by connection to band aid that
last over the wire at org is closed. And they
have given an oath if you solve this level
and see by by even trying to log into an ID
18 This is related to next level that is when
19 So of course we're gonna go to level 18.
The parser for the next level is stored in
a file readme in the home directory. Unfortunately,
someone has modified the dot bash RC file
to log you out when you log in with SSH not
an issue bandit. What I want to do is probably
we can inject command in SSH now let's see
let's go to man SSH I'm not aware man command
not found. Let's go to ssh that help. And
here we can see command argument it is specified
inside this braces not residence this brackets.
So probably what I can do is SSH paths and
then I can simply right over here LS and that
would probably do the job Yes, it has showed
readme if I do get reduced over here. So if
we give commands like this, we have received
the password over here. That's great. So this
is how we can inject command not inject command
this is this is not a vulnerability anyways,
this is a intentionally feature that has been
added that whenever connection is made, we
can run the commands real quick. So LS gave
us the content and cat readme and gave us
this. Let's do some more fun. There's like
this let's do ls LS
LS minus L A We'll be getting all those things.
Anyway so this is for level 19 So echo this
Never 19 But let's move ahead to level maintain
right now. And let's see what we have for
us wedding
so level 19 To gain access to the next level
you should be you should use the Set UID binary
because we have to tackle with the set UID
binary file in the home directory executed
without arguments to find out how to use it
the parser for the for this level we found
in the usual place this after you have used
the set UID binary file have, by mistake use
this command over here for which I'm not being
able to go inside Okay, so we're inside When
did 90 There's a set UID binary file what
the set UID binary file how to recognize that
if you see the file permissions real quick
there is s present S stands for set UID binary
file what that means is that this file is
having the privilege of bandit 20 But this
file is can be executed or can this file can
be run like bandit 19 can run this file and
this file has the permission of any 20 So
for the time being bandit 90 will be getting
the access of bandit 20s privilege. So the
time taken to run this particular set UID
binary file for that amount of time when did
19 will have the privilege of Vandy 20. So
we will be using or we will be taking the
taking the advantage of this particular good
news or good feature so it's a binary file
so I'll be using dot slash bandit 20 do hit
enter and it says run a command as another
user and it says ID so if I say Id it will
of course show my ID because I am running
it but of course it will show or give me leverage
of bandit 20 So if I do get it see
bandit pass bandit 20 Now since bandit 19
is actually seeing the content of bandit 20
So this is not actually permitted. But when
since I'm watching the content or seeing the
content of valid 20 using the binary file
so I will be getting the privilege of Monday
20 and hence I can what Oh, it's a spelling
mistake and hence I can actually view the
content of bandit 20 So this is the password
what I've done is I've given an underscore
over here rather I have to give a slash so
this is a password of Vandy 20.
Let's go and solve when the 20 Let's see what
do we get SSH paths switch to bandit 20 There
is a set UID binary file in the home directory
that does the following it makes a connection
to localhost and the port you specify as a
command line argument it then reads a line
of text from the connection and composite
the possible previous level with the possible
scope it will transmit the path to the next
level when 21 Okay so I have understood what
I have to do let me make you understand what
I have to do but before that I have to open
another terminal over here another instance
of my Linux shell and I have to SSH into bandit
20 once again
so let me go inside when the 29 inside went
20 Let me just get out the password of bent
20 This is the password and let me copy the
password and keep it in my clipboard because
I need it. What this challenge is saying that
there will be let me first go over here and
clear this terminal out ls there is a binary
file known as su Connect. What this will do
is if I execute it, it will tell me that usage
dot slash has to kind of and then a port number.
So, it will establish a connection into that
port. And what we need to do we have to establish
or we have to connect to that same port and
through the second shell we have to send the
password of the current user and and this
final file will compare the password of bandit
20 with the password that we have supplied.
If that matches then only it will send me
the password of bandit 21. So, the way we
will do it, I will first establish a Netcat
listener over here. So NC minus L V P L stands
for listen V stands for verbose, verbose will
give me all the output all back and output
out P stands for board support let it be triple
I went for twos or triple to four twos. And
over here, first let me start the connection.
Let me start the instance. So it says listening
on port 222 Double Double two. So that as
you collect so it will establish a connection
on tu tu tu tu or whatever will happen on
this particular port. We can see this on this
Netcat listener just over here. If I hit enter
you can see the visit prompt right over here.
And there is it says connection received on
localhost 44064. Now I have to paste the password
over here. And if I hit Enter, it gives us
a new password. But over here, it says read
the password that we have supplied. Let me
okay, the password you have supplied. And
it says we have read the password that we
have supplied and password matches sending
next password and we have got the next password
over here. So I'll be copying the password.
Let's hit ad set because that's not our use.
Let's save the password of bandit 21. And
let me close it from here as well. And let's
go ahead and switch the user to bandit 21.
A program is running automatically at regular
intervals from Cron. Okay, so we are having
or we have to deal with cron jobs. Again,
if we're not sure what kinds of means Cron
is a time scheduler kind of thing. That means
if we have something to do at this amount
of time, and you want to do it automatically,
you can set a cron job, which I have a trigger
and say it's a time based Job Scheduler, look
into Etsy cron dot d for the configuration
and see what command is being executed. Okay,
we will be having fun with cron jobs. Let's
see. ls Of course, they find nothing. So let's
go to et Cie. And cron dot d folder LS we
find lots of jobs over here. But we are interested
in bandit 22. That is running right over here.
So if I do ls minus L a cron job bandit 22
is a file which I can understand by seeing
that it is preceded with a minus or a hyphen,
which states that it's a file. So I'll look
at then cron job bandit 22. Hit enter. It
says add read reboot bandit 22 this particular
file actually this particular shell file is
getting executed and it is getting executed
at each and every our minute today's month
like that. So star mints wildcard if you don't
know So let's let us go ahead into this deep
directory real quick just to see what is actually
happening rather what we can do is we can
cat out the content probably Ctrl Shift C
It does a bash file it says ch mod 644 temp
and this file, cat Etsy banded past Monday
22 and redirect it to this file. So what we
can understand is first it is changing the
permission of this particular folder and then
it is saving the password into this particular
folder. So We can go ahead and we can go inside
this particular folder hit enter. It says
it's not a direct, okay, it's, it is a file,
I guess. Is it a file? Yes, it's a file and
look at get this file and we have got the
password over here. So this is a file inside
temp folder, which it has created if you are
confused what I have actually done, let me
solve the solution for you once again. So
there is a cron job when they 22. We are interested
in getting the password of bandit 22. And
let's ignore this 2324 And all those things.
So since these are files, so let's see what
these are doing, what are the scripts written.
So there is a script that is getting executed,
which is over here. So let's see what is the
content of that particular script. So that
is a shell script, which you can see over
here that hashtag our shebang, and then exclamation
mark, then slash bin slash bash, CH mod, it's
sending the permission of this particular
file and CAD it is getting out or taking the
password Vandy 22. And setting it or redirecting
or rather, saving the password or storing
the password in this particular file. So what
we have done, we have copied the file name
we have simply wet cat. And we have hit enter
and read it. How can we like how did we get
to understand that we can actually read the
file because of the permissions 644 I said,
four means read. So everybody can read at
six means there is two permissions read and
write that is four and two. So the user that
has created this particular file can both
read and write and rest of the world and the
groups can read it so we are having the read
permission. So we can read the file and we
can copy it we can exit out of it. fo this
is for level 22 Let's go ahead and let's go
and solve bandit 22. It says that a program
is running automatically at regular intervals
from cron, the time based Job Scheduler looking
at security for the configuration and see
what command is been executed look at the
shell script written by other people is a
very useful skill the script for this level
is intentionally made easy to read. If you
are having problem understanding what it does
try executing it see the debug information
it prints so let's go to first et Cie brown
dot d and since we are logged in as bandit
22 So we are interested in bandit 23 So cat
cron job bandit 23 And we can see the shell
script that is being executed as this so let's
go up it let's get it it says hashtag dollar
hashtag Islam question mark when bash my name
and then this nonsense that is being run by
user Vandy 23. So who am I will give us 123
So my name because 223 My target is equals
to echo I am user when the 23 taking it giving
it as MD five some
Okay, copying the parser file it's a valid
password My name that is manly 23 So copying
at Symantec pass manly 23 So to temp and then
the file name over here my target cat at see
when the 23 it is Echo okay the cat at Savannah
23 to my target okay. So what this is actually
doing is My name is equals to who am I? So,
in this case where am I will be banded 23
My target is equals to echo I am user my name
so echo I am user or mandate 23 and it is
being passed to MD five some so it is being
encrypted into MD five algorithm and then
there is a cut command so what will actually
happen is if I do not get like this so there
is a minus sign right over here so to remove
this minus sign they're using this command
command
if I also give okay
MD fives if I also give this and hit enter
I will be getting this file name over here
this MD five some if I copy it, and they are
storing this thing into a variable called
my target and that's what they're saying that
cat at sea when did When did 23 The parser
of when the 23 is installed into temp my target
so if I go to CD slash temp slash my target
not CD since they're getting it so it's file
it will be cat and here is the password
so let's save the password real quick and
this is for 23 great let's go to level 23
Let's see what do we have waiting for us normal
cron, please I'm tired of it. Oh again some
cron jobs okay. So a program is running automatically
at regular intervals from from the time this
job scheduler look in this for configuration
and server command has been executed same
thing. This level requires you to create your
own first shell script Okay, so this is a
very big step and you should be proud of yourself
when you beat this level. know to keep in
mind that your shell script is removed once
executed, so you may want to keep a copy around.
All right. Let's see. CD et Cie slash cron
dot d this is the folder where all the cron
jobs are listed and we are interested in bandit
24. Since we are logged in as Vandy 23. So
get cron jobs bandit 24 and the shell script
that is being executed is this let's read
the shell script and it says again bandit
24 It is going inside Where's spool my name
and foo my name will be of course their mandate
24 It is doing for i n star dot star so whatsoever
file name with whatsoever extension do if
filename not equals to dot and file name not
equals to dot.so if the file name is not a
hidden file or not a hidden directory then
I'm not sure what this is doing. Stat minus
owners format wasn't viewed or slash. So basically
what I can understand is it is kind of executing
the file after 60 seconds because timeout
you can see minus four seconds I don't know
what nine means but 60 seconds and dot slash
alright so whatever file is present inside
where spool to end where many 24 Fu the files
present inside there are once executed, it's
six second and then they are being removed.
And it is being executed by bandits 24. So
we can actually see the password of Vandy
24. Great, so I'm having a very fishy idea.
And I think that's what they want us to do
to create our own first shell script. So I'll
be going inside CD where spool there's a bandaid
24 by two Ls I get to see full over here.
I don't know whether you can see or not. Let's
go to full. Not full sorry, full. Of course
I cannot do ls I need to make a file. So let's
do Nano. And suppose the file is give me pass.sh.
And inside that I've arrived at hashtag shebang,
dollar slash bin slash bash as to know that
we are writing a bash file and I will be redirecting
cat at sea when that boss slash bandit 24
password to them I might have trouble doing
this because I'm not having any folder created
by default. So what can happen is if I close
it right now, and before actually making the
file, let me go to the temp folder and make
a directory so that I can receive the password.
So MK dir gay game 255 CD game to buy five
whatsoever and now I'll be going to this where
spool bandit 24 Who and then I'll be making
a script over here past.sh And then I'll be
writing slash bin slash bash, get et Cie.
Then when that boss and I do not have so much
of time because it is going to execute every
60 seconds mandate 24 and save it inside a
temp folder inside game 255 as a file name
pass underscore received, and the spelling
is wrong which we shouldn't be careful about
caring about Ctrl X Y and before hitting Enter
the file name is pas.sh so ch mod 777 fast.sh
At least they were this time sorry date it's
55 So after five seconds so we should be getting
our file if I do ls and before that, that
we do that and of course 60 has been passed
or not passed in the past so if I go to El
Sol real quick demo
game 255 We have got nothing that's weird
probably we were late and when you I having
the past.sh again it's for the six over here.
Are we having this file
passed on sh no we don't rather we have I
don't know man no boss.sh We do not have that.
So I have to make it once again. And with
that let's see slash bandit underscore paths
slash bandit 24 redirect it to them. Game
255 under name paths received and Ctrl X Y
enter ch more 7772 paths.sh two paths dot
s h and let me see the time that's 53 Let's
wait for seven seconds. Till then let's go
to them and game 255 We have nothing current
over here. So we have not attained that's
pretty strange. We are
having nothing According to it, which should
be executed and we have given execution permission
as 777 this should have been deleted after
executing but I don't know why it is not getting
executed. Rather if I go to get at see bended
pass bandit 23 cyl, we're getting the password.
So let me keep a copy of it real quick. So
what I can do is I can make a file over here
before that let me copy the whole thing. Nano
start sh bin bash this one 24/7 TMP slash
game 25. Slash password by default ls pas.sh
Is their LS minus L A. We have to give readwrite
permission. So, as far as La it is having
readwrite permission now I'm going to
have lots of times so I'm going to copy this
path.sh into where spool ban the 24. Who.
And its check date. It's 42. If I do ls slash
var slash spool
and then mandate foo, and then pass.sh, it's
present over here.
And it has already been executed. But for
some reason, we are not getting the file.
And that's a very strange, I don't know what's
wrong with this. If I send the password file
the shell file once again. And if I do ls
minus l, it is having read write permissions
by due date, we're having much more time right
now. So this should have been working. I'm
not sure why it isn't. And it should be working.
Come on these work. And it is not working.
That's great. And it has been deleted as well.
So let's see, what wrong am I actually doing?
Let's go and read the source file once again.
But I realized real quick over here that one
thing that I was doing wrong that my this
particular folder that is game 25 is not actually
having the permission to receive any kind
of files because it is not having that permission
to receive files or to modify the like due
to the file permission issues. We are actually
facing this problem. So what I want to do
is CH mod 777 I'm giving readwrite execute
permission to this particular folder it is
game 255 And then if I CD game 255 And then
if I send this What is it time? I don't know
where that thing is. There it is. copy for
that, let me say, Okay, we have already passed
the time, CP past.sh to spool manager in the
port pool if I send it over there and if I
do ls minus L A, inside that pile that is
present in that spool folder spool when it
into portfolio, so it's having read write,
execute, and probably this time, we will be
getting the file, and it's 37. Let's wait
for this to become 60 then we might receive
our password file. So if I give dead it's
54 Let's do ls obtain nothing, nothing. And
here we received our password by default file.
That's great. So due to those file permission
issues, we were not being able to get the
content that means that script was actually
sending the password 24 file, but we were
not being able to receive it due to some file
permission issues. So silly me, I was not
aware of it. Ctrl Shift C. Exit it and echo.
Save it to 24 Let's go to 24 a daemon is listening
on port 30,002 and will give you the password
for when 25 If given the password for Vandy,
24, and a secret memory four digit PIN code
there is no way to retrieve the PIN code especially
except by going through all of the total commission
called brute forcing.
What does that even mean? Let's see. 2424
ls anything? Nope. Shall we go to Etsy, pronto,
D anything, they say 25 underscore route.
Daman is listening on port 30,002 Okay. All
right. This is not related to cron that I
have understood. Let me clear it out. If I
do NC and local post and try to connect on
30,002 I am a PIN code checker for using a
band 25 Please enter the password for us for
user when it 24 and secret PIN code or single
line separated by a space that means if the
password is a rather if I give the password
and 1111 Oops, it is having a timing as well.
What the hell 1111 It says wrong presented
the correct PIN code 1234 Wrong again. Okay.
So we need to do a brute force. That's great.
So the way we can do it of course by using
for loop so for i n 0000 It's a for combination
29999. And do what I'm trying to do is do
echo dollar I done and I am not a code alright
I will be saying echo the password and then
Dolerite done and whenever you will make the
combinations send it to NC on localhost at
Port 30,002 And do not encode this thing it
is much more hazardous ekomi dollar this and
actually perform this particular operations
with dollar eyes. So what I have done is let
me make you understand real quick for i n
000 to 99994 zeros 249 So it will make combination
of 000000010002 and so on till 9999 And on
each iteration is the value of But the value
will be stored in this variable i so i have
said do during each iterations it will show
me the value of it that is on first iteration
to so mysterious 0001 On second question like
that and it needs to perform an operation
give this the password and then dollar is
$1 I will the value will be stored and I'll
be taking the whole output and since I'm using
a pipe operator I'll be taking the whole output
and sending it to and see localhost this so
what this will happen now is a magic if I
hit ENTER
did not supply enough data did we fail we
shouldn't What the hell is that? Well what
command not found great that was that what
I was expecting I can do echo and then can
I do is it that 2002
a daemon is listening localhost Let's hit
Enter Oh we got it fairly did not supply enough
data whatsoever the parser for the user bandit
25 Is this great. So, let me just copy it
and why it was showing please You did not
supply enough data because this was being
sent dollarized only the PIN code was been
sent but this Damon needed two parameters
that is the password of the current level
and then the port and then the PIN code. So
if I remove this thing if I remove this dollar
echo from URL if I simply do like this it
will say Please enter the correct PIN code
try again and then the and then the password
there is a 25 is this
great let's copy it perfectly echo and store
it on 25 Let's go and have a look on challenge
25 was waiting for us logging into band 26
from 25 should be fairly easy the shelf of
any 26 is not been bashed with something else.
Find out what is it and how it works and how
to break out of it.
So we're in When did 25 ls bend it to Anderson's
dot SSH key so SSH minus i the identifier
name they use it user name is bandit 26. Add
the rate local host minus P two to zero. Hit
Enter click on yes I mean it says connection
to local host closed it says the shell for
user Vanitha innocence is not bash. What shell
is being used with Vandy 25 bin bash let's
go and see cat et Cie pass WD file spool of
gibberish written rep bandit 26 It is using
using short text. So what we can do is user
been short text and I see cat user been short
text now Okay, looks like a shell command
export term because to Linux execute more
parent tech dot txt I don't know what that
means. txt dot txt is it the banner that they're
printing? Probably I have no idea is it this
banner because it is different from what we
have, like, it is different from this banner?
Probably I don't know. So what we can do is
there is a more. Can we do anything with more?
I haven't used more since long time. Let's
see what we get over here. Can we execute
commands in more? Oh, we have got something
by the way. Vi is used to start up an editor,
specifically VI or Vim. Okay, so environment
shell. Okay, let's do one thing, what more
actually does it if I could give you a good
example. If I go CD over here, we have some
time. Let's make a file touch by file dot
txt, and let's run a loop for i n 0002 For
example, five by five
to echo dollar AI and file dot txt If I just
get by Allah txt, you can see all the numbers
are over here. But what more will do is if
I show it to you like this, and if I write
more and then file dot txt, it will give us
a prompt till here and we can use the down
arrow key to navigate you can see I'm using
the down arrow key
to see the content and then it says And so
it is giving us a prompt over here and that's
what we will be using right now. So if I do
this thing once again if I give vs. Forever
The I have to make the screen much bigger
or the text much bigger whatsoever I do doesn't
matter.
That's it. That's the vs I have to make the
screen much smaller I have understood can
exploit it. Okay, so you can see we have got
something like this. Oops. Again, we have
got to stop and then I will be pressing V.
So I am inside the VIM shell. That will keep
it like this. And let me minimize it. I'm
inside them. Now throughout right how to exit
vim I'll be showing you not worry for that
probably it's, it's to set if I could zoom
it for you.
Shell is equals to bin bash and like the unknown
option shell okay
I have forgot vim as well. I mean this was
can you write like that? No we cannot Yes,
I know that I'm in insert mode as to oh, we
have some are entered into insert mode and
I don't want that how to
exit when or how to not exit them how to take
them out of insert mode. Hit escape, okay.
Escaped. Okay, so it is and if I hit i It
doesn't exist. mode if I hit escape it is
a normal mode.
Great.
Actually not vim it was vi to set variables
in VI Yeah, it was it's to set was still said.
So, the gods to bin bash and then again is
to Shell roughly let's see this to let go.
Alright, so I believe we are facing certain
problems. Guess what? Let me try that once
again. If I do like this, since it is using
more, so we should we stopped over here, hit
V. So we are in vim right now
to customize that maximize at least let's
set it over here in a proper size is to our
to read a file that is et Cie slash banded
underscore path slash bandit 26. Is to R stands
for reading a file. Warning changing read
only file please enter a try command to continue
enter. And yes, over here we have received
the fire the password Ctrl Shift C of level
26. And how to quit is to Q. Underscore
hopefully. Nope. Yeah, but Is that Yeah. Epstein.
Hopefully it's done. I don't know. But it's
to underscore to maybe.
Let's see how to do it is to underscore Q
oops, sorry. It's still underscore Q or is
still Q Yeah, it's Tokyo whatsoever. Doesn't
matter. Let's exit out of it. And Echo is
the password that we have got and this is
off 26 That was an interesting thing. I didn't
use Vim or vi for so long I actually don't
use so often since I've got Visual Studio
Sublime Text and many other cool text editors
but that connection demanded less or closed
what and why is that so let's go to level
26 And let's see what challenges we have them
good job getting a shell Now hurry up and
grab the password for bandit 27 Oh I forgot
the value two and six is not using bash it
is using short text or something like that.
Can I use commando here like ls but what is
that that is none of our use. Go good job
getting a shell now hurry and grab the password
for bandit 27 commodity we need to solve this
level is Ls Interesting thing is how to get
inside is when 20 sets. What we can do is
if I go inside bandit 25 let's clear it out
let's search for the word command. So there
are various ways we can use command in Vim.
Is there any word for Shell so what we can
do is we then do the same stuff. We have got
this key and I don't think that it is present
over here. are red SSH minus I this that is
that key bandit 26 at the red local host minus
p 220. And since it is using more it should
stop and I'm using V over here and now it
should be fine and now I'll be using is to
set shell is equals to bin slash bash and
once it is said hello okay so this set not
everything is to shell and we have got real
shell over red so, if I do which bash you
can see we're using user bin bash. So, we
have actually set the variables and like previously
I was giving capital letter variable but over
here we had to give small letters so that
was working if I do ls we got band 27 do so
dot slash when the 27 do run command as another
user so simply get Etsy bandit for us and
bandit 27 and we will be getting the password
for bandit level 27 That's great. Let's exit
out of it.
Let's close it is still Q it's closed or closed
was that exit echo as 27 Now let's go to bandit
27 user let's see what do we have in level
27 There is a git repository at this location
the password for the bandit 27 kit is same
as the user manager 27 clone the repository
and find the parser for the next level.
clone the repository that means I have to
go inside temp make dir game 123 CD game 123
Let's do a git clone of this repo and hopefully
this replay existed and have it enter yes
What permission denied we're trying to login
into server on port 22 What that means even
just if I do ch mod 777 And then game 123
Is that fine what the hell please make sure
you have the correct access rights and the
repository exist what the hell that even means
permission denied could not read from remote
repository
that's one big issue and I don't know what
the to what I can do one thing is since I'm
not getting the permission to do is I'm using
another command that is make temp so it will
make a temporary folder in the temp directory
hopefully it was this I don't remember so
this folder has been created for me. So if
I go inside this folder and then if I do get
clone and then
SSH kill repo Then hit Enter oops, sorry this
says problem again and we're trying to log
into the server on port 22 which is not intended
and it says please make sure that you have
built access right which I do have but also
the repository exists which I'm not sure what
I don't know what why this is being shown
to me. Good ad thread local host Shall I do
something like localhost is to zero Yes, finally,
we have solved this. So local those other
two to zero valid 20 sevens password for the
password valid 27 at
RTW bandit. 27. So let's face it, hit enter.
And we have received CD Ribault so CD raphoe
ls gridway. Get read me the password to the
next level is this.
Okay, so exit. Go this next level that is
28. Great. Let's go to level 28. And I think
this has been changed recently because I have
seen many write ups and many other solutions
and walkthroughs in nowhere. I have actually
got the solution that I was facing, but private
regret corrected and I'm happy for that. Let's
go to level 28. It says there's a git repository
at this. So let me copy kaput before that
make them minus d CD slash temp slash DMP.
dot j UGVNGO G proabably and inside that git
clone this and after localhost just add the
port number 2220 and hit enter. Click on yes
it asks for the password of level 28 Let's
see. This password pasted over here. We have
worked report CD repo. ls that readme.md We
have got Catherine Minard. MD It says as the
source for level 29 credentials and password
is hidden. We have Git installed red.
And are we having the Git folder? Target Yes.
So that means we can see the comments that
has been made. So Git commit sorry I mean
commits I believe I don't know what was the
command let's see the Git what to say those
are cheat sheet let's open that okay, so I
was finding for logs. So git log. So it says
add missing data. So here's a commit Okay,
so copy and get checkout probably, let's go
ahead and see was that yeah great checkout
and then the COVID name, hit enter and then
if I do get read we probably get in the password.
So you can see what I've done is a rather
I would suggest you to go ahead and learn
it basically I have searched for the logs.
So the user has get first of all is a version
control system okay. So, you get logs gives
me the logs that number of time the particular
file has been changed or the readme.md file
has been changed and these are the some tokens
you can say some identifiers and I have used
this and I said that show me what changes
we have done on this particular identifier
and at that point of time, they have removed
this text and I've entered xx and all those
things. So this is the password so it exit
there go this and save it to level 29 Now
let's go to level 29 Real quick level 29 stage
there is a good report repository at this
the parser for the 2019 same clone the repository
and find the password for the next level.
Let me clear all these things. Make them minus
d and I'm not going to copy this and I know
that when I'll be copying this my repository
clipboard will be replaced so CD law inside
this and the simply clone the stain Ctrl Shift
C oops Ctrl C and Ctrl Shift V over here it
will ask me for the password for sure and
it's doing teen mine
click on yes
oh sorry. What I have done a mistake that
I did not add the port on Yes. The password
I've pasted received. See the repo. We have
got we have got a readme.md no password in
production. Tell me what are the branches
present is master and what are the branches
present? It's dev master and slides Dev. Good.
Love the pics user name. initial commit of
readme no password in production
open the cheat sheet Okay. Check out dev readme
and here we have got the password of mandatory.
So what I've done is they said that no password
in production. So it was in the master rank.
That means you can see it as the main branch.
But when I did virus R it showed me the several
branches as well there was the Masters plus
Dev. So dev stands for development. So if
it is not in production, it is in development
phase. So I said that a git checkout and then
dev so I want to visit that dev branch that
development branch and they said that switch
switch to a new branch Dev and then I did
ls to see what other folders present in that
branch folders and files. So when I did get
rid we I got the file this
So that was interesting echo this 230 Let's
switch from user 29 to user 30. There's a
git repository clone the repository and find
the password of text level
make them minus d go to this particular folder
and git clone this particular repo Ctrl C
Ctrl Shift V and in local host press 2220
that we copied over here give the permission
give the password hit enter clear LS and CD
repo LS good
readme.md just an empty file okay that law
of part logs log initial commit this which
is actually this get branch there's a head
branch and a master branch What can I do so,
what we can do is if I see over here will
not get any other things if I do ls minus
L A and PE go to see the dot get we get many
things and if I do ls minus r probably we
will be saying many many things
is kind of confusing if I get out description
nothing get config with a good index index
it's
not taking good head nothing as well if we
go to CD info exclude Of course not tank and
if we go inside CD logs good heard nothing
Wickard CD refs do we get anything if I go
to box obtain we get over here do we have
tags and get I don't know if I if we are actually
having tags or something like that good. Can
you tag someone because when I was having
your Tober fest when I participated in that
hack Tober fest over there there's something
called a stag but in the cheat sheet there
is a table of stairs. So, yeah, so good tag
will list all the tags out there. So, good
tag so there's a tag called a secret. Okay,
that's fine. How to see tag and get Show and
then tag. Okay, good show. Secret. And hopefully
that's the password for the next level which
is 31. So let's see let's go to level 31 This
says is a git repository at this okay Mac,
temporary directory and this directory take
me and I want to do a git clone. But before
that
give me the password of this one great and
localhost is 208, enter. Yes, I have copied
the password already.
Instead CD repo that ready, we that's that
readme May I come in master file and the time
your task is to push a file in a remote repository.
Okay, monster so let's make a file echo where
I come in and keep it in key dot txt there's
a key dot txt out there. And there's a Git
ignore file as well. So let's go ahead and
read that. Git ignore file. So it says any
file that comes in dot txt will be ignored.
So I have to remove this otherwise, if I push
this key dot txt into the master branch, this
will be deleted. So nano dot Git ignore and
I have to remove this Ctrl X Y enter. So now
if I do care, the Git ignore that thing is
there. Or I could have just removed the Git
ignore file as well. Our Git ignore simply
remove it. And then I think git commit ad
really good ad Okay, so good. Ad key dot txt
good. Let me see the status. Yes, new file
has been asked. Added it is in unstaged manner,
so we have to stage it. So let's comment.
Git commit minus m let's give a message. I
don't know what to do. Let's simply get commit.
What is that I have to give a message right?
Okay. That key dot txt one file change create
more key dot txt and now git push remote branch
Okay, so what if I do only git push? It requires
the branded 31 local host password. We Yeah,
I am already having it. Let's face the password.
It failed as well. Learn here is the password
for the next level. Okay, we have done it
so let's copy it exit and echo is probably
the password of level 32 How long it was 31
right level 32 So let's get ahead and let's
solve when did level 32
Let's see what is there in level 32 After
all this good stuff it's time for another
escape Good luck Welcome to uppercase shell
that means ls what the hell's that LS Hello
not found ls not found what the hell bad okay,
so it is using Bourne shell over here probably
it is not a normal bash shell it's born shells
it's bill you are the wall shell I don't know
what right once these are only two things
one shell manual
and it is taking two arguments okay so after
reading this manual, what I can find is that
if I press Ctrl C, of course the connection
will be closed. And what I've understood there
whatever commands I'll be writing it is getting
converted to uppercase. That means it is somewhat
related to positional arguments which I found
somewhere over here regarding all this you
can see parameter substitution and command
substitution. So in this parameter substitution,
if I give dollar zero let's see what we get.
We get a shell over here if I do ls we get
a PowerShell you can see and if I say which
bash rather which bash it says we are in usual
user bin bash so we have got a shell over
here a bash shell and now we can do an apt
see when that underscore pass and there's
not an interactive shell resists the normal
shell and banded it is I think 32 And we need
a password for 3333 probably 43 it also yes
so here is the password for bandit 33 So let's
go ahead and go that's 233 let's write and
said and to sit over here and Ctrl C
33 No such file seriously no such file oh
oh TW when that and then 33 and remove 33
from here
and remove file or txt from her which I have
made to show you how to mess with the more
command. Let's go to level 33 which is the
last one. At this moment level 34 doesn't
exist. ls I don't know what to say. ls readme
dot txt cat To readme dot txt it says congratulations
on solving the last level of this game at
this moment there are no more levels to play
in this game however we are constantly working
on new levels and will most likely test one
scheme with more levels soon keep an eye out
keep an eye out for announcement on our usual
communication channels in this meantime, you
could play some other war games if you have
an idea or some medieval please let us know.
All right. So this is the official end of
the bandit war game and posted or hosted by
over the wire a big big shout out and thank
you for over the wire to launch such a great
wargame which has taught many of you including
me, even after solving learn letter after
solving or after being in cybersecurity still
good band it has been proven very helpful
for me in refreshing on all those in revising
my basics and of course I believe it has helped
you in getting your feet wet and giving you
a very good and what to say a very good glance
of how tall you should be with your basics.
So this was a beginner friendly room and hopefully
you have learned a lot from this rule and
see you guys on the next one with another
video and till then have a great day and goodbye